earlier this year I played a game called
wanted dead and it was a bit of a mess
the storyline was all over the place
scenes just happen out of nowhere combat
was imbalanced the mini games were
frustrating and the only song you could
do karaoke to is 99 left balloons
I loved it I'd even say that it is my
favorite 6 out of 10 game of this year
so far am I being dead serious because
you might be like a six out of ten
really and yes absolutely in fact wanted
Dead has just got me thinking about this
whole review score thing in general
review scores mean different things to
different people and because of that the
interpretation of them can be incredibly
skewed I say this as a reviewer for
GameSpot
for a lot of people a six can be an
immediate no thank you but the thing is
bad games even the most aggressively
mediocre ones can be loved and great
games in their own right not only do I
defend the six out of ten but I think we
should learn to embrace those rather
colorful experiences
foreign
there's this sort of phenomena with
reviews especially when it comes to the
score it's like there's this obsession
with the number and the number alone you
know what I'm talking about in fact let
me show you something so this is the
audience retention for one of our video
reviews you see this Spike right here
yeah that's that's where we show the
score for the review that indicates that
people just jump into our reviews skip
to the end of the see the score before
they actually watch the rest of the
video and I'm sure if we had the stats
for the raid reviews that graph would
look the exact same way I think it's
pretty normal to look at a review for a
game you're interested in scroll to the
bottom maybe read the pros and cons
maybe even the concluding paragraph but
in most cases you're looking at the big
old number and then closing it out on
number lacks the context of the entire
rest of the review additionally I think
there's something even deeper to look at
and that is
a lot of variables first it's a gut
check on whether or not something is
worth your time or money it can be a
risk for you to drop dough on a game
that's potentially not great totally
reasonable but I think I'm more asking
you to really think about what compelled
you to be interested in that game in the
first place and why are we so deterred
if that game is anything less than
amazing let's look at how we here at
Gamespot categorize our review score
scale because it doesn't boil down to I
like it or I don't like it there's a
scale for a reason 10 is essential not
perfect but then we jump down to six
which means fair and five means mediocre
but that doesn't read as unplayable I
gave Delhi premonition 2 a 5 out of 10.
it's rough in some places
a lot of places but if you took my
review at the score alone you'd miss the
fact that I still think it will appeal
to a specific audience of Gamers just
not everyone and
I've actually played that game more than
once since I reviewed it
on multiple consoles
on the flip side I gave Resident Evil 4
remake a 10 out of 10 because I found
that game essential to the medium I find
it remarkable enough that if you play
games and love games then you should
seriously consider playing it for the
record I appreciate the review number
scale because it gives you an at a
glance understanding of where a game
Falls I just don't think it should be
the end all in determining whether or
not you play a game which brings us to
why I even played wanted dead in the
first place I knew nothing about this
game until I saw its launch trailer and
I had no idea what I was watching I was
confused but that's because the game
itself sort of seemed confused and no
context to what this game was no
preconceived notion of anticipating it
to be good or bad but it looked like it
was trying to be something even if it
didn't know what that something was then
I saw this clip and I immediately bought
it place your bed and let the Wheel of
Fortune make a choice for you
tonkotsu that's a good one
first You observe the bow
appreciate according to the record of
the Yokohama Rama Museum Ramen
originated in China and made its way to
Japan in 1859 that is what did it for me
and oh this game is certainly something
it's a hodgepodge of a cover shooter in
a hack and slash interspersed with an
eccentric cast of characters 80s pop
covers that play while you're running
around the police station or I'd rather
tonally inappropriate moments John
Wick's style action lots and lots of
blood and a convoluted storyline of
government conspiracies and Androids
with a conscience and you know what
coming off the highs of 2022's end of
the year discussions talk about games
like God of War Ragnarok Elden ring
immortality prestigious highly regarded
games even groundbreaking ones wanted
Dead served as an impeccable pellet
cleanser for all of that it was a
reminder to Simply love a game for
exactly what it is a video game and yes
it's got its problems ridiculous
difficulty spikes super spongy enemies
tonal confusion from cutscene to cut
scene plot lines seemingly go nowhere
and again you can only do karaoke to one
song and yet even its problems made the
game
all the more memorable
it's a game that tiptoes on the verge of
being a total disaster while also being
something I could not stop playing it's
hard to say any of this is intentional
but it's wonky unevenness kept me
captivated it is through and through the
encapsulation of what I would rate as a
six out of ten now I have found that a
lot of the games that I love just so
happen to fall in that six out of 10
range for whatever reason in fact I
would say that lower scores often make
me more interested and or inclined to
play a game
foreign
X-Files resistor sir flower sun and Rain
D2 gun grave Gore to me these are all
personal six out of tens by current
standards and don't reflect that of
Gamespot scores of these games these are
all games that I have played in the past
year that have lingered with me just as
much as the eights or the nines or the
tens each of these games fell in one
place but are successful or even unique
in other places X-Files resist or serve
distinctly captures the spirit of the
show and is a serviceable survival
horror with great atmosphere the camera
however is a nightmare combat is
absolute it's certainly not the
prettiest thing to look at and you fight
a zombie with an AK-47 in a post office
6 out of 10. then there's flower sun and
rain it is a fever dream on Loop with
funny writing but monotonous almost
patronizing mechanics that feel designed
to specifically annoy the player like
the step counter in the corner that only
emphasizes how much time you've been
walking around doing just about nothing
and yet I have never played anything
like it before or since six out of 10.
it might sound hokey but games like
flower sun and Rain remind me that art
is often meant to be judged on its own
terms on its own merits it's about
seeing a game for what it is rather than
what it isn't
or it could be as simple as admitting
that you know bad games can be fun too
like a cheap beer and oven made pizza it
all serves its purpose and that is
exactly what gun grave Gore is to me
in all honesty I began playing gun grave
Gore for irony sake because it was on
Game Pass and frankly it looked
incredibly dumb
and it was but something happened the
next day I came home from work and I
kept playing it because it's actually
incredibly stupid fun I mean it says
kick their ass at the beginning of every
level
and I'll leave it at that
foreign
like where you should read bad books
watch bad movies even listen to bad
music because it can sometimes inform
you of what you like better than the
stuff you actually like does but I also
think the opposite can be true too with
games in a lot of cases you'll often
find genuinely interesting ideas and
Innovation that may not have been fully
formed in a six out of ten the contrast
however is that some big budgeted AAA
games that are attempting to appeal to
the broadest Market possible aren't as
willing to test new ideas they're much
more risk averse they want to appeal to
everyone they're looking for that safe
number at the bottom of a review and of
course this isn't the case for all six
out of tens but I'm willing to bet that
you're more likely to find an oddball
mechanic or even a wacky idea in one of
those games then you are in the safer
bets so let this be an Ode to the wonky
Games The Wacky ones the not so great
ones and and maybe the even more daring
ones that don't always shoot to the top
of greatness but still manage to hit
some sort of spot one thing I do
understand at least is that each of us
is likely choosing a very specific
reason for why we play the games that we
play and it's why I think game scores
can be so divisive because of course we
want to be validating the thing we're
excited for and besides we're creatures
of hyperbole that's just the way it is
but I will ask the next time you're
reading a review and you find yourself
gravitating towards this whole bit maybe
consider you know reading the text too
because you never know you might be
surprised as to what your next favorite
game is
and what score might be as well I've
seen some in my life but this is a
whole new level
hey before you go I just want to give a
quick shout out to an article the
Gamespot published over 10 years ago
also titled in defense of the 6.0 by Tom
McShay which just goes to show that this
is something that is as true then as it
is today with that said if you like
stuff like this well thank you for
watching and good news for you because
we got a whole show dedicated to these
sort of stories including our first
episode which was on remakes and
remastered so be sure to check that out
if your heart does so desire alright see
you next week till next time so long